hi i'm christopher hines today i'm going
to talk to you about a conron flowwizza
drill that i use for the kyowasa so
that's a lot of things to say all at
once so we're going to talk about the
kiawaza and how they flow they conren
into another one and conrad just means
adaptive so how we can adapt one kyowasa
into another kyowasa i'm gonna get josh
out here we're gonna go to work josh
all right so let's talk about a kyowaza
flow drill that i use
kiowas is ikyo through rokyo in my
school i know some schools have nanakyo
and there's differences of opinion about
what goes where but we use six
i'll show you the six right now and
the way that i i start to get my
students working through them i think
kind of ingrains the ideas of the
kilwaza2u better than the forms do
initially meaning that you'll kind of
see
why one technique will feed another
technique and and this goes in a really
nice progression of one through six um
but they could go in many different
progressions once you kind of understand
this basic idea so this starts from the
shomonuchi position the very first kill
was as ee and so that's controlling the
underside of the elbow right here so if
they can if i control the underside of
their elbow then i i can push them away
from me or whatever it is i can do right
so that turns out real good for me all
right now in that if i go into ikyo and
they grab me and i can't get them off
and they start working their elbow down
and they're stronger than me then i
don't have an eq and you see he gets
anikia for that right and so in fact if
you've taken a uh need on test that's
the that's the conrad or the kaishi for
it okay so i'm here like this as he
pushes the elbow down what i'm going to
do is immediately go to nikki so you see
i'm using his desire to get out of ekyo
to go into nikki now this is a little
bit of a contrived way to show it
because generally i believe this nico
should be used as hidoki like that but
we're keeping it so we can kind of flow
a little more here okay now if i start
to work nico and he raises his elbow of
course i have ikkyo again but i also now
have sankyo as you can see i can come
into sankyo and control him there and
that's because his elbow went back up if
he tries to drop his elbow down and
that's what would take the sankhya over
so if he dropped his arm this way he
could throw me back that way right so if
he can drive that arm down that's no
good for me so what i do is i slide my
hand here and i get yonkyo and now by
being in the yunkan position if he
pushes his elbow down he hates it right
it's no good so that's not not a good
position for him but now let's say this
is a real brute of a guy and he can
drive it down anyways i catch him in
here and i get gokyo and this is often
called to come along people like to call
this come along but so this is goku over
here i'm crushing the wrist now if he
doesn't like me crushing that wrist he's
going to shoot his arm out of there and
that's going to give me rokyo right here
so the rokio sets up in the form of
myotosh so myotosh is also a rokyo
anytime i'm going against the elbow
that's roku
now what's important to understand about
this is
in aikido if you're dealing with an arm
in any martial art if you're dealing
with an arm the arm only has three
positions right the arm can be straight
the hand can be up from a straight arm
or the hand can be down from a straight
arm that's it and up and down's relative
to the person up is towards their head
hand towards their head and down his
hand towards their feet right so it's
either going to be straight up or down
aikido has lots of ways to solve that
and generally when you're trying to do a
technique to someone people are going to
counter your technique by going in the
opposite direction right so for example
if i'm trying to push josh's elbow up
josh is going to push his elbow down now
from the context that we have right here
when he pushes his elbow down i get nico
for it okay now if i'm trying to do a
technique that involves his elbow down
he's going to do the opposite which is
raised his elbow up now of course i
understand ekyo's there but also
sankyo's there now if we're in this up
elbow position and he wants to
transition down i could slide my hand
here so when he tries to go down it
doesn't like it anymore right and he
shoots his l before which again gives me
the eq or the sankyo if i wanted either
of those but if i tried that technique
and it failed and it came down anyways i
can still trap his arm in this little
cradle right here which is a form of
gokyo and there's several goku's like
this this is an it right and then if i'm
trying to get do something to his arm he
shoots his arm straight to be strong i
could get rokyo now i said these could
go together in different ways so
understand if i was trying to do sankyo
and he straightened his arm to get out
of the sunkyo and it did it weakened by
sunkyo i still have rokyo because a
straight arm is a rokyo technique right
let's say i was going into a i'm just
making one up that's kind of crazy here
let's say i'm going into enikyo and he
wants to raise his elbow up right from
this i can go to ikyo or i could go to
sankyo or i can go to anything that's
elbow up so that's the way you should be
thinking about instead of thinking that
the techniques are limited to first
shionage has to happen and our first
shonuchi has to happen and then this has
to happen and that has to happen it's
limiting the way you can do your
techniques but when you understand that
the kill was that each feed each other
one kilwaza leads into another kyowasa
and generally when a kyowasa can't
happen we use a nagewaza to upset their
balance so we reset the situation so
that's kind of the systematic way these
techniques are working so this little
flow drill is a nice way to kind of work
through the kill was and get your
students thinking about how one
technique can lead to another and how
they they feed each other when things go
wrong
i'm christopher hines this is joshua tv
my solano mcdaniels behind the camera
thank you for watching